I'm a writer because because I just
finish on me do it I really don't know
why well I think they're fine fine all
right now you've got a cry stuff
the biggest reason you don't know what
you want to do is you haven't tasted
enough things and the biggest reason
you're not tasting enough things is
you're worried about finding it too fast
start with the finish line all right
too many people are just worried about
tomorrow go backwards from what you want
to achieve financially and in your
legacy and then make all your behavior
every day map to your finish line the
way that it can that a 20 year old can
make the world better twenty or thirty
years down the line is by making
themselves better first I think I think
people don't realize that the way to be
selfless is to be selfish it's very hard
to change the world if you're not good
to me when I look around this many
people being in their 20s like
everybody's judging themselves way too
early what I would do is gather as many
experiences as possible you know you're
not lost in life you're just early in
the process
morning blog just jumped on Instagram
for their live feature and brought
people in that was super fun and
waiting for Raisa now we have a nice
solid 15 16 hour day
that concludes you're back at the hotel
I feel really good about a lot of stuff
it's got a lot going on a very
vaynermedia it out just to kind of give
you an update I've been really focused
on the offense a lot of incredible
things happening at vaynermedia a lot of
new business coming in a lot of
assessing talent a lot of bringing new
talent a lot of assessing the offerings
but feeling incredibly confident and
very excited about the you know acts as
a whole spend a lot of time we pure wow
you saw Ryan Harwood in a couple
episodes it was hard to hide that
beautiful face and just incredible stuff
happening a pure Wow and just in general
like some really hardcore momentum in
the Vayner ex holding company and bio
made some incredible hires got three or
four more incredible hires that are
signed sealed and delivered and will be
announced shortly I think a lot of
people in the advertising world the ad
world are going to be taking it back for
you guys this is hard to understand but
a lot of people in the Madison Avenue
you know that cliche 3040 50 year
veteran in the ad world doesn't respect
what I'm doing heats the pressure I'm
putting on the status quo I'm business
meetings where people literally spend
the first 20 minutes talking about
Russia invading America through its
Facebook's and this is then to the and
then all of a sudden we get to marketing
and they tell me Facebook's not that big
they should still do television I'm like
wait a minute what about the first 20
minutes when you said our entire
governments being overthrown by social
media but now to sell your blouses or
your soda it's not important so I think
the only thing that's changed is
people's acceptance of it and it's scale
the Internet
is the biggest thing that has happened
to human beings ever and and I don't
think we realize that because it's too
early
my big thing is that I think we over we
overestimate things staying the same
like we're basically having an IBM
Microsoft conversation the thought that
Facebook and Google will in perpetuity
dominate the digital landscape is
laughable at best
Amazon's clearly gonna be a third player
in the next 24 months like what happens
when it's voice or its AR or I mean what
happens when it's a VR I don't you know
and that may be 25 years away from
consumer VR at scale and blockchain and
all these things that are happening
disruption never really happens because
somebody had guts and took the leap it's
that they were forced into it and it's
coming into form that I didn't expect
it's coming in the fact that the TV
networks are losing to OTT so if there's
no commercials what do you do and it's
coming in the form of activist investors
disrupting the biggest marketers in the
world and there's some thirteen-year-old
girl in India right now that Elon Musk
has completely inspired and what's she
up to
so I think it's interesting because I
look around and some of us are younger
than others I think it's gonna be a good
chunk of our lives what we're talking
about for next 10-15 years but I think
the biggest thing I've learned is man
everything we think you know don't let
Facebook go and everything don't let
Amazon earlier they don't let the two
china companies own everything the
problem is and everything changes and so
well I don't think it's bad cuz I don't
think it's sustainable because it's
never been historically sustainable no
company has ever run a 50 year run on
controlling anything like retail is
gonna start spending more money with you
guys because they're about to go out of
business all of them like you know
somebody woke up this morning said wow
Lord & Taylor's stores shut down in
Manhattan like it's just real it's when
Toys R Us goes out of business then the
other retailers are like wait a minute
this is not gonna happen because of a
good thing this is gonna happen because
of a bad brands are gonna change their
behavior because when they start looking
around and saying we're next they're
gonna get scared they're gonna do it out
of defense not offense which is very
unfortunate like polo is gonna go out of
business right a huge gun so real
systemic disruption happens on defense
not offense problem is it doesn't matter
what they like it doesn't matter what I
want to happen the results in the
execution are [ __ ]
and that's what I focus on period just
because I figured out how to store email
in a modern way with incredible human
beings and the infrastructure and team
and strategies and unbelievable
understanding of the modern [ __ ]
ecosystem doesn't take away from the
fact that I'm [ __ ] executing 17 hours
a day as a CEO of an 800 person 150
million dollar plus holding company and
you know what I'm super [ __ ] proud of
it I no question I'm more proud of me
the executive than me the personality
it's not even close now
the impact on the hundreds of emails
that I get from you every day about the
impact I've had one way or the other
motivation or execution that's a bigger
legacy than the company that I'm
building so I'm scratching both itches
and I'm not too worried about other
people's opinions on it because I know
what the finish line looks like by the
way just to clarify that wink was the
[ __ ] to you to everybody who thinks
they're gonna beat me you've got to know
if you're gonna go after 22:27 and
you're gonna defeat all these
competitors you're gonna have to start
younger their behaviors happening at 15
16 17 they're selling to each other that
are buying clothes off each other and
sneakers and slime on Instagram the
behavior starts earlier and so we're
gonna have to think about that in some
shape or form I understand that you have
different restrictions maybe you guys
fund a startup that you have an option
to buy this needs very smart thinking
but you're not gonna win if you spend a
hundred million dollars on 2227 if you
rock your favorite game
I came from there so good at this game
easy rock oh thank you how are you I
don't want to bother I think you should
be thinking about audio very
aggressively nobody in your space has
won the podcast I think it's hugely open
I think I think I can't believe that
BuzzFeed and 9gag and you guys and
others haven't gone into the podcast now
it's hard
you got a strut you got to do a meme
radio show but what do you do with the
podcast in this videos in the boys not
picking up
I mean picked up in the US but in
Singapore you try to the first thing I
would do is look at it and see if how
true that is because don't forget again
it's always hard with in a country small
so it might be picking up it's just
proportionate you know 300 million or
back to Indonesia to you know to you
know laser 250 like you know like
Indonesia 250 million like if it's 5
million if 50,000 are doing it that
means a lot so you just have to look
what that means and then the question
for them becomes you know I think that
with the 9gag thing you have to be smart
about like what so what's this is that
the holding company but it's not
consumer facing so I would probably use
a podcast for all of Southeast Asia and
use that as the opportunity this is
where I do strategy I would use a
podcast which will leapfrog your
competitors that's where I would
probably establish the brand that's the
consumer facing holding of em gag s gag
I'd probably not use gag because you
don't want a creak room you know I don't
and I mean I was an investor but I've
seen him once though my trip to Hong
Kong the other day so I don't have any
disproportionate feelings towards 9gag
or not you'd probably want to be smart
about how you think about it that's how
I think about it
because you understand why I believe so
it's like uber right or Facebook
podcasting has won here let me tell you
why
audio is gonna win with human beings
because it saves time so some things are
binary and human not cultural time is
human so it will win here it's just
updating just had an awesome meeting
with some incredibly intriguing
Singaporean I'm ready I'm gonna just
just vlog it over here no big deal just
a little blogging vlog just to catch you
up the rock and I've been this we're
traveling here chatting for the last
little bit and I was about to say
something I was like hey pick up the
camera cuz it's gonna really help people
I think our ambition if you listen to
Dirac and I talked for the last 15
minutes you guys would laugh because
we're basically [ __ ] on everything
we're doing content lies and in the in a
good way not like like just we're just
critiquing and I was about to say I want
to catch it on film because it's so
important our ambition to be great is
driving this whole thing way way way
more than I think people would realize
you know for us to be at a standard of
content output and quality that we're at
and let's call it what it is it's really
hard for another human being to to claim
that they're at this level we're just
[ __ ] bringing it right now across all
platforms audio written video all
different networks LinkedIn Facebook
Instagram snap and yet
we're at three to five percent of what
we could be doing we just have so much
to do obviously every time I'm in Asia
I'm like we got to transcribe every
[ __ ] piece of content to every
[ __ ] language you know there's so
much more to be done that video that got
over a million views on Instagram about
the youtuber kid I feel like there's
five of them a week but we're we're not
putting those out
god there's a lot to do I think law of
attraction works in a lot of Kandra I'm
a very big believer of a year just
watching you to see you in Hong Kong
today I think it was humble be hungry be
hardworking and
because of this I I do I think it's very
hard to help if you're not from a
position of helping I see I see so many
young people rightfully so in it it
makes me admire them be so altruistic
yet they're so weak inside themselves so
they put up a facade because they they
act as though they want to help the
world as a way to build confidence a
facade it's ego and that's fine and it's
a lot better than other things so I
don't judge it's just I wasn't able to
give this much back until I scratched a
couple things for myself and I think
about that it's tough to give from a
place of instability and whether its
financial or street cred or whatever one
needs I always want somebody to get
theirs first so that they can give later
I genuinely think about things like that
you can't build a beautiful room and be
a great interior decorator unless you're
a great contractor and build a great
steel foundation for that building and
that then gets into my patients in your
20s and 30s pour concrete and build
steel don't worry about putting [ __ ]
curtains or what color to paint the room
right there biggest advantages your
youth
and too many and too many kids don't
take advantage of time they're in such a
rush to find it or be doing it that they
don't take advantage of the thing they
have which is you could do nothing
successful for the next eight years
how'd are you you can literally do
nothing for next eight years and be a
child but you don't think that because
when you're twenty - you don't think
thirty-one is young but it is patience
patience you know whether it's your
parents or yourself or people
everybody's trying to prove something so
early yeah I mean that's you know it's
oh wait everybody's got strengths and
weaknesses what what a 60 year old has
is experienced but doesn't have time so
they trade on experience what youth has
is time you can literally do four
different things over the next two years
six months at a time to figure out
everything that you think you might like
you should try to do but that's not what
people tell you to do so hundred percent
thank you so much you're welcome you're
not lost in life you're just early in
the process you know what I mean you're
lost by other people's standards not by
your actual if you actually took it
practically you're you haven't even
started to many people view post
University as like oh [ __ ] this is now
real and I'm lost they don't put it in
the context of being alive for a hundred
years and realizing they're only 20% of
the way done got it
copy its perspective almost everything I
hey everyone no everything is
perspective like I think I think I'm
just starting so imagine what I think
for most of you
maybe you gotta go thank so much Gary
you all see you there grabbing me guys
let me just say hello let's do it
take it off or do someone to you keep
the drive how can you be so energetic
like this every day yeah like like the
question you asked me do you sleep are
you a robot like I think I think the
thing with me that I've come to realize
look I think I have a lot of natural DNA
there's energy that I have that I'm like
every time people first come across me
the amount of comments that say that I'm
on drugs or things that they it makes me
laugh and it makes the people that know
me the best laughs I guess I don't I
don't even smoke a cigarette let alone
you know I mean the amount of people
that write things like cocaine ritalin
like they've you know I get it I
understand why so clearly I have natural
energy and always have but I do think
that energy comes from gratitude
I'm awfully grateful I think that people
take life for granted I think they take
circumstance for granted it is stunning
to me that the majority of people that
are watching this right now have
firstworldproblems I think I got very
lucky that I came from very humble
beginnings so I know what it tastes like
I'm grateful I'm grateful I'm really
grateful and that's it that you know if
you're truly purely grateful you'll have
more energy than you'll ever need
thank you you're welcome to make
traveling yeah of course
[Music]
[Applause]
patience and a lot of people like the
[ __ ]
I guess and just work on your thing I
guess just keep doing it yeah it's my
biggest thing I really want to flood you
know as much content as I can but to
really bring bring value and at the same
time you know to be able to connect to
with with my audience so that's really
what I wanted I learned about being
self-aware and about I think just being
yourself and and similarly don't know
[ __ ] I just learned everything that
could learn from Gary be basically just
about life about marketing and how to
place myself position myself for the
future Gary Vee man is that nothing is
out of the realm of possibility if you
want to get somewhere you want to get
into conference even if you don't have a
ticket you can get in now what did I
learn today or anything new but I got a
reinforcement from Gary Vaynerchuk that
cut out all the [ __ ] just do the
work stop making excuses
put in the effort put at the time don't
put your energy into useless activities
like you can watch Game of Thrones when
you retire you can take part on credit
communities discussing the one episode
of the other after you after you retired
I'm sure they'll exist in the future of
AI and ml but right now is the time to
put in the work while you have the
energy to stop making excuse me this
guy's do [ __ ]
[Music]
start with the finish line all right too
many people are just worried about
tomorrow go backwards from what you want
to achieve financially and in your
legacy and then make all your behavior
every day map to your finish line I want
to be a great entrepreneur that inspires
others that's why I'm still sitting here
know what your finish line is and work
backwards
[Music]
[Music]